Hey, can you use, okay.
It's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation.
So we'll start with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from
a four, so from the number four,
you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern.
And then with that one, any mistakes that you make,
if it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of a 0.1.
If it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing.
So say we're doing a,
how to mark.
If it's not your shoulder height,
maybe it's a little bit lower,
or maybe it's a tiny bit higher.
That's a minor mistake.
So that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be,
you're supposed to do it out of block in the pattern,
but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead.
So that would be a major mistake.
So with a minor mistake,
let's say pattern one, for example,
there's 20 steps.
It's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14,
15 mistakes in the 20 minute pattern.
Sorry, the 20 steps.
So the reason for that would be,
it needs to be absolutely perfect to get,
to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So it's not uncommon, let's say there's 20 steps
and you made, let's say 15 mistakes.
So what would that be?
So we'll leave that there on this side
and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the score at the end.
So a major mistake,
say you're supposed to turn to the left,
but you turn to the right,
that would be a major mistake.
So obviously we do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes.
So after we've done our pattern,
that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So the presentation, as you can see,
it's from a score of six.
This six is actually split up into three parts.
So we have one, two, three here.
So with this one,
for a score of two is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of two
and your expression of energy is also scored out of two as well.
So we'll start off with the power and speed.
So with this one, whether it's your blocks,
your kicks, your strikes, your punches,
anything that you do,
you need to be nice and strong
and it has to be fast as well.
So it's one thing to have a very strong punch
or a very fast punch,
but it has to be both strong and fast
to get high in that energy.
The next part is your rhythm.
So the rhythm,
when you do start your pattern,
there is a rhythm to the pattern.
It's not just really fast all the way through.
It's not slow all the way through.
There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect as well.
So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm
and that's also scored out of two.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So what is expression of energy?
So that's basically how loud you shout,
so how much intensity you have.
So that's kind of what you're doing
during your pattern as well.
So say you're doing your pattern really well,
it's really fast and it's strong,
your rhythm is really great,
but you're not shouting very loud
or you can kind of tell,
the judges can kind of tell
you're not really confident,
you're a little bit nervous,
so that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So I'll just come around to this side.
So with this one,
for color belts and black belts,
it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So if you're a color belt,
you'll actually,
your average,
so where the judges actually mark you from,
it's actually from a 1.1.
So this is your average.
So say you did alright,
you did average compared to everyone else,
your score for one, two and three
will start from a 1.1.
So if you're less than average
in the judges' eyes,
you might go down to,
say for your power and speed,
you might get a one
or even a 0.9.
If you did really great,
you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So each individual category,
you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt,
generally depending on the competition,
you will be scored from a 1.3.
So 1.3 would be your average
that you start from.
So say your power and speed
was above average,
you might get scored a one point,
say,
let's say 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average,
it wasn't amazing,
it might be just a 1.3,
but let's say you didn't shout very loud,
so your expression of energy,
your average was 1.3,
it might drop to say,
let's say a 1.0.
So with this one,
we'll comment down to this side.
as I was saying,
it's a total of 10.
So let's see.
Before presentation,
we had 1.7,
1, 2, 3,
so you had a 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So with this one,
obviously don't be too discouraged
if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is,
with the judges,
we have three judges usually at the panel
and each judge obviously is very subjective.
So,
um,
from their point of view,
you might have made a lot of mistakes
or you may,
may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So that's why we have the three judges
and we average it out as well.
Okay.
So,
uh,
say we did our,
15 mistakes,
very small mistakes.
So,
if they're all,
uh,
minus 0.1,
it'd be,
uh,
1.5.
So you go,
4.0 minus,
uh,
1.5,
which equals
1.5.
So this would be your accuracy score.
So,
with our presentation like before,
we're saying we got a 3.7 here.
So we,
we add these numbers at the,
uh,
after the judges are finished scoring.
So you would get,
for this pattern,
a 6.2,
which is actually very good.
So,
I'll just talk about a little bit more now
about this number here.
So,
if you're a color belt,
uh,
if you're a yellow,
black belt,
and you do your patterns,
it's not uncommon,
generally for a color belt,
uh,
the average is about a 4 to 5.
So,
if you get a number between,
uh,
4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern,
that's actually,
uh,
generally considered pretty good.
So anything above that,
uh,
you can consider yourself pretty good.
Uh,
if you're a black belt,
the average would say,
because,
um,
we're talking here about,
uh,
the,
the high red belt,
uh,
the,
the high presentation as an average,
anything from 5 to,
uh,
to,
sorry,
5 to 6 is actually considered,
uh,
pretty,
pretty good.
And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world class.
So,
if you get a 7 for any of your patterns,
you generally need to,
uh,
pat yourself on the back,
you did an amazing job.
So,
uh,
we just went through our Poomsae scoring.
So,
just remember,
accuracy is a 4,
4.0.
So,
uh,
the,
the presentation is a 4,
4.0.
Presentation is a 6.0.
Accuracy is judge during your pattern.
Presentation is after.
And then we get,
uh,
the two scores that we add up.
And we get that number.
So,
with this one,
obviously,
uh,
say I was,
I was judge number one.
I would give you a 6.2.
There was another,
another judge on the other side.
Maybe he saw a couple more mistakes,
uh,
than I did.
So,
maybe this one would be a little bit lower.
It might be a 5 point something.
So,
I would give you a 6.2.
There was another,
another judge on the other side.
5 point something.
Another judge,
uh,
on the other side.
They scored a little bit higher.
So,
we'd get the three numbers.
And then we'd average that as well.
So,
uh,
I hope this,
helped you guys.
So,
uh,
make sure you enjoy your Pumpto competitions.
And,
anytime,
uh,
make sure,
obviously,
you,
record down your numbers as well.
So,
it's very important to,
to keep track of your numbers.
And,
to see if you're improving.
Good.
Okay.
So,
we're going to continue.
Yes.
Minor errors,
you can push.
So,
you can watch your own.
Yep.
And then,
score yourself.
major errors.
Okay.
We cannot pause this time.
You can only look like,
pretend like you're the real judge.
Okay,
sure.
Without pausing.
Yeah,
yeah.
And then,
power and,
after the performance,
you can,
power and speed,
coordination of rhythm,
and then,
expression of energy.
Okay,
good.
Good job,
good job.
Okay.
So,
let's go now.
Okay.
No,
no,
I,
I'm going to,
I'm going to be very careful with what I say.
But,
I,
Thank you.